I already know that I'm gonna get
roasted for this I'm going to drag you
we're here to see which movies are
holiday movies and which movies are not
holiday movies you'll say they are to
sound edgy at parties a Christmas movie
to me it needs to be on or around
Christmas time and it needs to have the
Christmas spirit which means happy
message at the end about love and peace
and all that bull if there's a Santa hat
in the movie then it has a potential to
be a holiday movie in my opinion a
Christmas movie has to have some kind of
like joy and something about Christmas I
think Christmas needs to be at the
center of the story it can't be just a
setting it has to be just kind of part
of the turn of events and also
preferably in the title like a Christmas
story or the Santa Claus this is gonna
be my throw line through a lot of this
the you know I feel like there's a lot
of movies that take place during
Christmas and that doesn't automatically
make it a Christmas movie there was like
a cute Christmas scene where Harry was
like oh like I'm an orphan like I ain't
got presents and then I think missed
means we like made in the HD scarf and I
think that's when he got the cloak of
invisibility
[Music]
I'm gonna go with no oh yeah I have a
daughter I seen frozen a million times
I've had enough times I've probably seen
the most more than most people watching
who want parents and I can clearly and
ethically and confidently say that it is
not a Christmas movie and it's just an
icy movie I'd watch it for holiday cheer
like leading up to Christmas mmm like
December 11th
oh no we knows where my rules Christmas
isn't entitled oh it's a Halloween movie
I would also agree with what I will say
is you can make a very good argument for
either I would say it is a Christmas
movie and not wholly you movie I will it
is not a wholly I repeat it is not a
Hollywood if the if the thing you're
celebrating is ending at the top of the
movie it is not that movie it's a
Halloween movie and a Christmas movie
end of discussion
it is mother Scotia
[Music]
it's drizzling Christmas aw yeah I've
got it I've got a great argument for
those two okay so it happens around
Christmas there's a beautiful Christmas
tree there's a beautiful Christmas scene
where she's dancing in fake snow that
he's created for her it's a love story
sad tragic love story but the love story
nonetheless and he makes the snow for
her every year on Christmas you put it
on the line here we're gonna see does
the revelation he makes us know for
every Christmas it's that the final
scene of the movie
still catch me dancing in it
yes it is yes Christmas memory Amanda
you film you get on oh yes there's a lot
of killing in there and it's on
Christmas it's Christmas Day it's a
movie on Christmas Day it's an action
movie that takes place during Christmas
not a Christmas movie Christmas is not
at the crust if the marriage would have
been saved at the end of die hard I
would have let it slide as a Christmas
movie but no what we see is Professor
Snape fallin to fire I think diehards
are Christmas movie because like what
better way to show your love of
Christmas let's be ready to die hard
[Music]
hard no hardly well hard no yes mugger
not a girl you don't like Christmas know
it is my Christmas movie yes yesterday
no it's not one there's not two there's
not three there are four Christmas Santa
hi again 90 minutes 90 minutes of this
movie but like there are three minutes
of Christmas they also have Halloween in
there they've got Valentine's Day in
there we could also argue that it's a
Halloween movie or a Valentine's Day
movie oh that is totally a Christmas
movie I've seen that one and yes it is
Christmas it's a Christmas movie it's
the cheesy one that you're kind of
talking about where like it's a love
story at the crust on finding love on
Christmas you know just in time to not
have to buy someone a gift because
usually what a Christmas movie has it
has a lesson and has cheered it as love
and it's funny
yes another one of those pesky taking
place your home you'd you're too worried
about the gremlins even focus on the
fact that Christmas is even there you
like all these cute things
I gotcha it's uh you fed it yeah no
absolutely not a kiss baby no I'm gonna
go with the dough and say no because I
feel like this is how we got picks is
that normalized that
oh this thing is I'm gonna go guess with
Carl yeah what I think of Carol I think
of Rudy Mara and a Santa hat I mean my
criteria it's not necessarily a
Christmas movie but I just I'm partial
to that he'll though long movie about
not love about things that do not
represent love it's really sad because
there's infidelity there's a guy in love
with his best friend's wife and
expresses it in the most irresponsible
way possible I felt like this is a movie
that challenges the way we perceive
loves and shows us what love is
oh actually no I stand with where I came
in
just because it happens around December
25th is not making a Christmas movie and
how dare you think just because there's
a Santa hat it makes it a Christmas okay
I got my convictions have not been
changed I still stand true I think that
if the pinnacle scene in the movie
involves Christmas a Christmas tree a
Santa Claus hat Phil I feel good about
it I feel like you know we've helped a
lot of you now the next time you had a
party in someone's like my favorite
person who's die hard I gave you some
hot spicy takes it throw at their face
and make that person to stop talking to
you and I just hope you reconsider Love
Actually the pinnacle scene in the movie
was a Christmas scene and there was love
[Music]
you